well everyone welcome to something new
today
uh for the last three and a bit years
I've been doing a weekly q a about
science and technology for kids and
others I've also been doing uh
alternating weeks
uh q a about history of Science and
Technology and one about business
Innovation and managing life
today I'm starting a new series which
will be alternating an alternate weeks
with the Q a for kids and others and the
new topic is q a about a future of of
science and technology so I've got every
other week A History of Science and
Technology and every other week
um a future of Science and Technology
you know I realized I've now been doing
um uh these a lot of these live streams
I have about 330 hours of recorded live
streams enough to train quite an llm uh
that will be coming soon too
all right
well let's see we've got all kinds of
questions here
um
Ollie is asking aside from faster
processing speeds what are some other
ways computers may be improved in the
future
you know one of the things that I
thought about a number of years ago now
is I was actually I was visiting the The
Archives of Gottfried leibniz who lived
in the late 1600s and uh who with great
effort made a a four function calculator
mechanical calculator out of brass and
so on and I realized at that moment of
seeing his his calculator I realized in
leibniz's life and he spent many decades
actually trying to refine this
calculator he had seen one computer the
thing he made
and maybe he saw a few others from other
people but basically he'd seen on the
order of one computer
in today's world we have I don't know
some number of tens of billions of
computers around the world
and computers are common things that we
see in various places what I sort of
realized at some point is that one day
people will be surprised that there was
a time when everything wasn't made of
computers what do I mean by that well
you know you go back more than 100 years
every material that you had was somehow
a material that in some form occurred in
nature then things like Plastics were
invented which were sort of artificial
chemicals that were sort of at the
chemical level constructed for
particular purposes and so on but those
things are just materials they don't
they don't compute in in the kind of way
that we think about computers as
computing and I think the thing that we
can imagine is that in the future the
kinds of things that we can program will
become ever kind of smaller and more
ubiquitous and I think that one of the
things that we see with with the
computer as of today is there's a
microprocessor it's made out of silicon
it's it uses Electronics Etc et cetera
et cetera there's clearly other ways to
be able to compute other than by using
electronics and silicon and so on in
fact my own science work has kind of
shown rather clearly I think with this
principle of computational equivalence
that there's a huge range of different
kinds of systems different kinds of
infrastructure that you can use to
compute with whether it's fluids flowing
around in certain patterns whether it's
other kinds of uh of things that are
transporting molecules around all sorts
of different ways of basically being
able to compute
and of course we have one spectacular
example of computation that happens
differently from the way it happens in
Silicon with electronics and so on which
is biological life and molecular biology
and so on I mean molecular biology I
view as being sort of an example of
computing where the working fluid is not
electrons and electronics but instead is
all kinds of different types of
molecules and so on that are being sort
of carefully orchestrated to move in
different ways and cells and things like
that I mean I used to think well inside
a cell it's kind of a liquid where the
bunch of molecules just bumping around
and you can compute with molecules just
bumping around as well but I think that
there's what the increasing evidence for
molecular biology is that things are
much more orchestrated than one expected
in their actual structures that sort of
move molecules and arrange them in
particular ways so in any case that's
sort of an example of where we have one
one case of molecular scale Computing I
think that there are certain certainly
others that do not rely on the kind of
History biological evolution that use
the idea of molecules moving around and
and sort of tubes that that transport
molecules and molecules of certain
shapes that fit in like certain puzzle
pieces and so on these are ideas that
are sort of the meta ideas of biology
that I think we can expect to eventually
make uh technological make things that
we can kind of produce in ways that we
want to produce them so I I'm sort of
expecting that uh there will be in in
some sense it will be the case that
there will be materials that aren't just
sort of static things made of
Arrangements of atoms and molecules and
so on that just sit where they sit but
things where there's actual processes
that go on that might involve electrons
might involve other kinds of atoms
molecules whatever their actual
processes that go on that we can think
of as being computations that our
computations that have been arranged to
be things that we can sort of Imagine
achieving goals that we have
so sometimes we'll be able to readily
Define sort of every step in what those
computations are sometimes we might just
Define the overall goals and then it
might be up to some uh some system kind
of uh arranging itself in order to
achieve that goal like you can have
something where there's a particular way
the puzzle pieces fit together and you
expect to have the system that's sort of
bumping the pieces around randomly just
as happens in molecular biology it's
sort of bumping the molecules around
randomly and the ones that happen to fit
by shape geometrically are the things
that arrange themselves that way one can
imagine the same kind of thing happening
but the main point is that there'll be
kind of a a sort of everything will be
will compute and there'll be ways to
kind of tell it what you want to do I
don't know maybe maybe there'll be
something where you're sort of uh you
know you've got some material in your
flashing light in some way at it or
something to be able to or more likely
you have something which is some kind of
phased array of different things that
are is sort of sending photons at
different parts of the material in
different ways and so on but in any case
whether where the result is that sort of
everything that one has will be made of
computers so to speak it will be made of
something that is computational
and I I would say that in a sense
biology is already doing that you know
biological tissue mostly has sort of
things that are
non-trivial things that are happening in
it it's not just sitting there I mean
not true of all of it I suppose but uh
some of it is just sitting there for
structural purposes and so on but plenty
of it has sort of things that are going
on in that in that tissue so I mean I
think that's the that's the big picture
in the in the distant future for what
will happen I think with computers it
won't be that computers are discrete
things it'll be that that one makes
things out of sort of computational
kinds of components
I think um
there are sort of nearer term things but
we can see like like one of the big ones
is when we look at current AI systems
large language models things like that
one of the features of those is that
they they do training and then you take
the trained neural net and then you run
it and those are sort of two separate
kinds of things and as you run the train
neural net it's not immediately learning
more stuff in brains we learn more stuff
as we run so to speak
and part of the reason it works that way
is that sort of in the training of a
neural net you're saying well there's
this part that's been sort of processed
in the CPU and most of the neural net is
just maintained in memory and isn't
changing but it isn't the case that we
have computers that are set up so that
every part of the network is sort of
actively computational it's it's usually
most of the network is just stored in
memory where the only computation that's
happening is just keeping it the same
whereas and there's a small part that's
actually the part that you're sort of
back propagating through or whatever
else it is that is the part where actual
change is happening where actual sort of
non-trivial computation is happening my
assumption is that in the not too
distant future it will be possible to
make kind of systems where one can sort
of compute and remember at kind of the
same time actually I just recently found
some stuff that I did in the oh gosh
early 1980s I was interested in making I
call Meta chips
uh kind of old-fashioned word for chips
microprocessors whatever and and the
idea was the following that right now
you make a microprocessor and it has a
billion transistors on it and it's
arranged like a giant you know City the
size of the Earth or something with all
these roads and things where electrons
go down them and they're all these all
these detailed features that have uh
little pieces of memory for keeping
things in in a cache on the on the CPU
chip there are things that arithmetic
logic units that actually do sort of uh
arithmetic computations all those kinds
of things they're all encoded in the
detailed kind of giant road map that is
the pattern the Circuit of the
microprocessor
so the idea that I had in the early
1980s was well what if you just use one
of these cellular automaton things that
I've studied a lot very simple set of
rules with very with the collection of
identical elements where you just have
the simple rule being applied and it
turns out that as a result of this
principle of computational equivalence
idea even in lots of simple cellular
automata it's possible to make a
universal computer it's possible in
effect to have a compiler that will
convert any program you might imagine
making into the initial conditions for
the cellular automaton for example the
rule 110 cellular automaton is one where
we know that's that works that way it's
just something where it's a
one-dimensional cellular automaton just
a line of cells each one is Black or
White at every step the color of a new
cell is determined by some rule
according to the color of that that cell
the previous color of that cell and the
colors of its two neighbors so
incredibly trivial kind of setup and the
idea would be you make a a piece of
Hardware that's incredibly efficient at
doing that particular running that
particular cellular automaton Rule and
you can you can do all kinds of
optimizations and and so on where all
the hardware does it's just a giant
thing that just runs that rule and then
sort of everything else that has to
happen is a software problem how do you
turn this sort of computation that you
want to do this I don't know image
processing task this compression task
this I don't know what any other kind of
task how do you compile it into rule 110
code so to speak
and nobody has really developed I've
done a little bit on it and few other
people have done some things on it kind
of how that compiler would really work
we know in principle that it can work
but to make it all efficient is a
challenging thing I mean by the way if
somebody just came to you and said by
the way all all you ever need is the
nand operation that's the only logic
operation you need and you put a billion
of those together and you can have a
microprocessor and it's going to do all
these interesting computational things
at first you would say how could that
possibly work it's just a simple nand
operation it hardly does anything how
can you put it together do complicated
things but this is one of the sort of
big results of lots of science I've done
for example that even when you have very
simple components you put them together
it is possible for the overall behavior
of the system to be very complicated we
see that again with llms and chat GPT
and so on Another Story Another
repetition of the same kind of story
that it's very counter-intuitive what
can emerge judge from putting together
even very simple components but any case
the the idea of these kind of meta trips
is you kind of put everything even the
design of the uh sort of everything is
in software the the actual thing that is
the microprocessor is something
incredibly simple by the way I mean in
the trend in microprocessors in general
there was a an early Trend that was uh
oh we make a we put all kinds of
complicated instructions and we we
encode that originally it was in in
circuitry and microcode things like that
then it was in Microbus as a design we
encode all these complicated operations
that do you know polynomial
multiplication and all sorts of things
we make instructions that do that in the
microprocessor and then in the 80s I
guess this idea of risk reduced
instruction set Computing came in where
the idea was let's keep let's have much
simpler instructions on the
microprocessor
um but then use a compiler to just take
the big things we want to do and grind
it down into these simpler instructions
and and it turned out you could make
very efficient compilers that do that
and in the end it was a bigger win
because you had to have a simpler
microprocessor you could make it more
optimized and so on I think the pendulum
has swung a little bit back as we see
gpus and things like that with a lot of
complicated operations and instructions
on them that are being that being used
but kind of this mentorship idea is the
ultimate risk it's it's kind of the the
thing that there's just this one
operation that's incredibly simple and
everything else is sort of up to the
compiler to make work so that's another
direction we might we might see things
going although it's always a a um uh
it's always a complicated thing because
you know one has an idea that says okay
well we'll make a more well
a general trend has been more good stuff
gets done in software less stuff gets
done in Hardware
um but then occasionally people realize
well there's certain things that one
typically wants to do in the hardware
let's just build Hardware that does that
and then that trans tends to lock in a
platform a framework
in which one then operates and which one
then does things with software so even
if the framework wasn't quite right by
the time it's kind of been optimized in
the hardware that's kind of how it
evolves
well that was I see we have lots and
lots of questions here so I'm let me try
and keep going here
uh
read it loud asks will we use books in
five to ten years or will it be replaced
by chatting with an AI
um interesting question
you know when the web kind of developed
in the 1990s and Beyond
I wondered that question I wondered you
know when do I want a website when do I
want to book
what I realized about books is
they're actually a pretty good form
factor and they're pretty good when you
pick up a book you know whatever this
book author or whatever whatever they
have to say it's in this thing it's in
this limited object that you can hold in
your hands
abundance websites it's kind of like
well I can click on this page and I go
to this page and I go to that page and
I'm exploring and I don't know how how
far the octopus goes out it's kind of a
thing where I can't get this sort of
feeling of there's this there's this
sort of thing that I can kind of ingest
the knowledge from in in kind of one go
so I think that having this notion I
mean for me I've been surprised at the
extent to which I really prefer sort of
larger scale things as books where I can
pick the whole thing up I know what it
is I can flip through the pages and so
on rather than it's a website it's got
hyperlinks to here and there and the
other
um
now in terms of
is it going to be useful to be actually
sitting and reading a book you know I I
think I'm probably a pretty bad example
of being a systematic reader of books
from beginning to end I tend to be a try
and get the information I want out of
this thing and so and that's something
where one can imagine that's sort of an
AI that is the interface to the book you
know I view uh what we have with track
GPT and so on the big thing that it's
introducing is this kind of notion of a
linguistic user interface
and I think one of the things that is
absolutely the case is that one will be
able to take sort of book type
information and say or a report somebody
gave you and you can ask a question that
is the thing that you actually care
about from that report and say okay tell
me the answer to this and this
linguistic user interface mechanism is
going to be able to give you the here's
what you might care about from this and
I think one thing we'll see is as these
systems get merged more and more with
kind of our personal histories it will
be more and more the case that somebody
shows you something that there will be
an AI that can say here's why you should
care about this here's how this relates
to something you've thought about or
written about or whatever before and
that's that's something where you know
when people send me things and they say
here's the thing it's interesting and
I'm like it's a lot of work to read this
if somebody could tell me how this
relates to things I already know and how
to plug that in to the things that are
already sort of lodged In My Memory that
would really help me and so I think
that's the thing we will absolutely see
from from AIS is they get to know us and
that gives them a way to explain things
to us in particular not to the general
reader but to us in particular now that
works when you know what you're asking
when you don't know what you're asking
and the question is to learn something
completely new then that is not a
successful an approach it's something
where I never knew to ask about that so
I'm never going to ask about it so I'm
never going to learn about it
so I think that's a place where again
the the here's a thing it's a book for
example and you can kind of flip through
it and you kind of Wonder oh what does
that mean what what does that uh sort of
picture about now maybe the AIS will
learn how to show us sort of a simulated
flipping that is useful to us in
particular possibly that will happen but
I still think that for me it's been
surprising that even in this time of
sort of uh uh everything can be
represented electronically
computationally digitally whatever that
I still find myself finding books really
quite useful even things I've written
myself I will sometimes look at the book
version of them in uh in preference to
an online version even though the online
version is nice and searchable and it's
this and it's that but somehow the book
version has a certain browse ability
that is perhaps helped by the fact that
well yes we are sort of physical
entities with fingers and this kind of
thing and you know there's some pretty
good kind of interfaces that are
provided by sort of our fingers ability
to flip through a book and so on
um and yes you know one could certainly
imagine that in the sort of future world
of extended reality and augmented
reality and so on there'll be uh
there'll be other ways to do this as yet
unimagined
um I think though what tends to be the
limiting factor is in the end you're
interested in stuff all this stuff in
your brain and for now we've just got
brains as as they are with eyes as they
are and so on and so you kind of have to
have to sort of interface whatever that
that ocean of knowledge is with the
actual uh apparatus that we have
let's see
um
there's a comment here from VM I think
about things moving towards narrative
driven ai-powered procedural generated
VR environments with sort of meta-human
characters interacting with AI speech
and so on like create me a movie
experience yeah I think um uh the um
um
it's really an interesting question what
the best way to
learn something is as a human you know I
think one of the things we're going to
see in the pretty short term is vastly
more personalized education
of of okay I want to learn something
okay AI teach it to me AI you know lots
about me you know a bunch of stuff that
I already know you can also probe what I
know and what I don't know and you can
kind of map out this is the exact right
thing to say at this moment that will
try and communicate this point in a way
that will fit in with my with my brain I
mean like if you started telling me
about oh I don't know what's the feel I
don't know terribly well economics let's
say there's certain things I know in
economics other things I don't know
there's things that I've sort of
understood and and really ingested and
there are other things where I where I
haven't and if you knew what I knew you
would be much better equipped if there's
some particular idea about I don't know
the uh some particular economic
situation or something where it's a
question of can you explain that to me
and you know you start talking about
Supply demand curves okay I understand
those you start talking about the you
know Smith Jones utility function
whatever which I've never heard of that
doesn't really help me very much but if
the AI knows what I know in a sense it
can in a very even even at the simplest
level kind of customize its explanation
for to fill in the parts to to reach
those kind of islands of dry land that I
can kind of you know that I can
successfully uh uh stand on so to speak
um and uh and not get kind of mired in
the ocean of things that I don't
understand it's so and I think that will
be true for for everybody
um I think that this whole sort of
mapping out of what we understand what
we don't understand what we already
remember what we don't uh kind of the
interface to the contents of our minds
that will be something that AIS will do
quite well
um I think this question of whether it's
better to kind of have the AI just write
your piece of text or whether it's
better to synthesize kind of you know
meet Socrates and person type thing and
you know have the discussion right there
with the embodied Socrates in in virtual
reality or something uh I don't know
that might be very compelling if it gets
to the point where it's sort of almost
realistic it could be a very compelling
experience because we are after all
evolved to exist in embodied form in the
actual physical environment and so on
and sort of there's a lot of sensory
information
that is coming to us that isn't well
captured by just reading words on a page
so it could be a very very compelling
thing I think when it isn't quite right
it's kind of in this uncanny valley
situation of being kind of well it's
almost to Socrates talking to me but the
Socrates is kind of has uh uh is is is
being very banal and and um not very
convincing and doesn't you know I'm not
I'm not getting the Socrates Vibe so to
speak
um and uh and that might not work very
well and it's a question of you know how
when does it get to the point where it
really is compelling and do people lose
interest before it gets compelling I
mean in a sense that's been the story of
virtual reality for the last I don't
know 30 something years is it keeps on
getting to a certain point but it isn't
that compelling and then people kind of
lose interest and it goes down into a
into a kind of a trough again and we'll
see when it when it finally gets to the
point where it really is sort of
convincing and and useful in that way
let's see probably one of these comments
can't read books on the computer Beyond
200 Pages too much eye strain uh yeah I
wonder about that I mean I I
I also
I mean I I think part of the story of
you know I strain computers et cetera et
cetera et cetera I mean in a sense it's
photons coming to the eye and it's
details of your computer screen and
there are a lot of details that really
matter like for example the actual
formation of font characters and whether
they're little you know bits cut out of
the font characters and so on it really
makes a difference to readability of
things uh particularly you know sort of
long-term readability these things that
you barely notice I think also there are
oh all sorts of detailed things about
refresh rates about uh you know the
actual colors on the screen Etc et
cetera et cetera I'm not sure I've
personally you know I think I made some
effort to optimize these things for
myself but I haven't really done a
hugely scientific study of what makes
for Optimal Reading for example I I
don't even know uh you know I I'm not
particularly a dark mode user in fact I
really haven't used it much at all
for me dark mode is what I used to use
um back until about the mid-1980s it was
dark mode only because that's all you
had that was what a cathode ray tube CRT
you know display it was illum you know
characters illuminated on a black
background and I find it amusing that
for the current generation you know the
younger generation it's like dark mode
this is really cool it's new well
actually it's what it originally was
when computers first existed with
display units and so on and uh so I
haven't yet sort of gone back to the
past so to speak for dark mode I don't
know whether it's faster to read things
in that way or not
um I think uh those are things I haven't
haven't optimized but my guess is that
there is a way for any given person or
maybe it's different for different
people of presenting things in digital
form in a way that's sort of optimized
for uh for readability and not giving
oneself eye strain of some kind I mean I
know know you know for example with
virtual reality it's still the case that
you know although I admit I have not
tried in the last year or so but at
least as of a year or so ago uh when I
use VR systems even the fine highest NVR
systems I was still getting motion sick
and I think that's to do with the
tracking of uh whether there's a lag
between uh image moving and head moving
and so on and that's really a a a a a
question of of the hardware and so on
and it will presumably gradually get
better
uh
let's see there's a question here from
math online are we close to imitating
senses of smell and touch in VR
interesting question
um
you know one of the things about vision
is that we have three kinds of color
receptors
plus one more kind of just black and
white receptors
and that means when we want to show a
color scene we can do that by just
picking the level of red green and blue
for each pixel
but if you want to make a texture
you want to make something of a certain
texture it's much more complicated
because we don't seem to have that
limited number of texture receptors same
with smell same with taste
let's take smell as an example there are
certainly hundreds of different kinds of
receptor cells chemical receptors and
our noses and so on and what's roughly
happening in smell is that molecules in
ways that are not fully understood I
would say are bind to The receptors and
you know you've got a bunch of molecules
that are the smell of a lilac or
something and that's a whole Cascade of
you know millions of molecules and they
get in our noses and these molecules
bump up against these different kinds of
of chemical sensors and to some of those
chemical sensors they'll be it'll be a
match and and it's probably a a sort of
a physical geometrical match probably
those pieces of lilac scent or whatever
that are probably
um uh will be uh
things that physically are of the right
shape to fit into a certain molecule
that is part of the smell receptor in
your nose and when when the thing fits
in that produces a signal which
ultimately turns into an electrical
signal and nerve cell and off it goes to
the olfactory bulb in the brain and uh a
new sense a smell and but what's
happening there is there are a lot more
types of receptors than there seem to be
for color I mean for color even if you
have that special blue that is made with
this particular Spectrum doesn't really
matter to a human eye what matters to
human eye is just how much red how much
green how much blue and that's why when
you look at a computer screen you can
see it's just made of red green blue
pixels but in the case of of um
of something like smell you have to have
this sort of it's like could you make
this collection of standard shaped
molecules and you can say I can make any
smell by having this particular
combination of molecules you know back
in the day in one of those it didn't
really work out very well I think there
was the smell-o-rama uh type of thing
for movies and so on where people would
have whether it would be have some some
kind of chemical kit that would sort of
open itself up at the appropriate time
in the movie and you'd smell something
and I think those had a certain set of
of chemicals in them that would produce
certain kinds of scents but when it
comes to sort of sculpting a scent or
sculpting a smell it's really pretty
difficult I know perfume manufacturers
for example they'll have hundreds of
different uh kinds of molecules in their
sense
um and it's not like with color where
it's just like they're three things and
you just have to get the right
concentration of each thing it's much
more complex than that same with taste
uh taste buds in the tongue and so on
are these pretty complicated kind of um
receptacles where bad particles of food
get in there and uh their actual
chemical reactions that are going on in
there and some of the effects of those
chemical reactions are what lead to the
sense of taste and I don't think it's
fully understood how that all works and
to what extent kind of the solubility in
water matters Etc et cetera Etc so
that's why kind of when you're kind of
making foods and so on there's a there's
a kind of a very wide range of uh you
know when you when you pick a color so
to speak you can in principle just move
around the red green blue sliders and
you're going to get that color and
there's no elaborate preparation
required for the color so to speak
whereas with food when you're trying to
make things sort of a at a molecular
scale you're trying to make a thing that
has a certain taste it's a really
complicated story and you know in the
end the sort of um Molecular Gastronomy
kind of idea of let's even understand it
down to the molecular level but but that
isn't even enough because it's not even
the individual molecules it matters what
the texture of the food is it matters
sort of how big the particles are and
that presumably has to do with Hazard or
how it fits in the tongue and so on now
when it comes to touch
touch is also really complicated and you
might ask are there certain kinds of
textures other sort of standard kinds of
textures oh it's rough oh it's slidy oh
it's furry oh it's whatever else
are there those kinds of limited number
of degrees of freedom for texture
there's been work done in recent years
that kind of suggests that yes you can
reduce it to a a limited number of
dimensions of kind of texture now and
then the question is when your finger
moves over that texture what's actually
happening and it's kind of sticking
slipping on the these different parts of
this kind of mountainscape that is the
texture and so on and I think then the
question is okay is there a way to sort
of make a device that will emulate that
texture for example you might even have
uh some mems or something where you
physically are moving little tiny tiny
things up and down to make an actual
texture but actually there are
electrical ways to do that where you can
get the sensation of something with
texture and I guess this was used for a
while on on smartphones but I'm now I
don't think there's anything that uses
that right now maybe I'm wrong maybe
there's a small such effect that I don't
even know is there that is helping one
when one's actually touching the surface
of a of an iPhone or something and I
know um
I think in the distant past when the
original way of determining just where
are you pressing on that iPhone screen
that was a thing that uh I happen to
know somebody used our uh uh wolfen
language technology stack to do the
modeling for that
um and it's kind of this question about
oh you've got this big pudgy finger
that's that's poking the iPhone screen
what actual place is the place is if
you've got this whole array of letters
which letter is the one that you most
think it's likely to be pressing and
that's a whole story of kind of
estimating that based on the kind of
distribution of of uh of squashed finger
so to speak on the iPhone screen and how
that is affected by the grid of little
wires that that pick up the electrical
signal from that in any case there is a
mechanism for
um kind of a feeding back electrical
signals that gives one the sensation of
a texture and I don't know how
successful that's been
um
the uh
let's see so so this question of how
this will work in VR
um good question I mean I think that you
know we can get a sense of how difficult
certain kinds of senses are to emulate
so for example we just look at our
brains and we look at the number of
nerve fibers that go from our different
sensory organs you know from from eyes
it's like 10 million fibers from the ear
it's like 50 000 fibers
and for us humans the number of fibers
going from our noses is smaller than
that I forget how many ten thousand
maybe I'm not sure
um for a dog or something it's immensely
more fibrous going from the nose than
from uh I don't know about the ears for
a dog but but um the dogs have huge
numbers of of nerve fibers that are kind
of um sending data from their noses
and so that gives one some sense you
know okay
historically you know 1990s we got
fairly uh as if you were there audio you
know you you sample audio at 44
kilohertz that's uh sampled high enough
it's above the range of human hearing
you can kind of get every single kind of
pressure sensation getting to your ears
that you would have if you were actually
there so to speak we're not quite there
yet in terms of eyes we're getting
really quite close but we're not quite
there yet we've got to hit that it
really is enough that all those 10
million nerve fibers are being fed the
same way they would be fed if he were
just looking out into the into the
everyday world and one of the big things
with VR was just getting the angle you
know as you look your eyes have a fairly
wide field of view and uh uh you know
just getting a display that wasn't just
in front of you but also a little bit to
the side was an important thing even
though the dance positive of nerve cells
on the on your retina of photoreceptors
on your retina goes down as you go away
from the center you still have some
sense of what's going on in the
periphery and that was important to
capture so I don't know for some of
these other sensors like touch for
example
um it's it's unclear how how good you
have to get it in order for it to be
kind of oh yes that's realistically like
picking up a uh
um a rough you know I don't know an
avocado or something you know it feels
like I'm picking up an avocado
um because it has sort of the same level
of roughness as that
let's see
um
s is asking saying they lost their sense
of smell during brain energy injury in
2016 and he realistic way this could
ever be fixed
you know I think one thing about brains
which we're also kind of learning about
llms is
brain tissue is kind of
it's sort of a bit Universal in the
sense that you've got all these neurons
they're all connected together yes it
tends to be the case that particular
functions are localized in particular
parts of the brain and that probably
happens well for different people
functions are localized in different
places like The Language Center of the
brain is is never in the same place for
two different people which is why when
people are doing neurosurgery and
they're worrying you know where is The
Language Center we don't want to mess
with that it's always something we have
to actually stimulate it to find out
where it is because it's just a bunch of
neurons like all the other neurons in
there
and I think the thing that is an
interesting question for llm's image
generation AIS things like that in fact
I've just been doing some experiments on
this myself is what happens when you
give them brain lesions what happens
when you zap some neurons inside a
trained llm and what you find is oh it's
really weird I mean it's really weird
what you find in terms of images it
produces these weird images and and then
eventually it kind of Fades to Human
incomprehensibility
um but I think what tends to be the case
with with brains is that it really is
neural tissue is in some sense fairly
Universal at least in the main cortex
part of the brain
um and uh that means that it is possible
for people to remap and it happens when
people lose their sight and things like
this they remap parts of the brain to
take over some neurons to use for a
different purpose
I think that the place where things are
difficult is when uh the actual nerves
that go from sensory organs to the brain
are damaged in some way like the
auditory nerve or the optic nerve or
something like that
um in that case really the only way that
you can get the data there is to
stimulate directly that part of the
brain
um without uh without going through
those those uh those damaged nerves so
for example for vision that will be
simulating the primary visual cortex in
the back of the brain and I think there
have been there's been
um well there's there's definitely
some success at sort of a low resolution
because in the case of of um uh
a vision there's a pretty direct
geometrical mapping between that spot in
your visual field and a particular place
in your primary visual cortex and so you
can expect to have some plausible
mapping of oh yes there's this visual
scene that's being seen by some
electronic camera and then that's
stimulating some particular part of the
brain now it gets more difficult when
there are things like smell for example
where the mapping from what the chemical
sensor senses to where that goes in the
brain is more complicated there's no
obvious geometrical mapping there's an
obvious geometrical way to represent
smells you know this is one of the
questions of of sort of how do how high
dimensional is smell space and you know
how many parameters are really important
there Etc et cetera et cetera by the way
I should say that when it comes to
making an artificial nose that's been a
long-running kind of can anybody do this
type question and I just saw some stuff
very recently of another effort at this
that looks quite promising but it's been
a long road and it's really difficult
and one imagines that sort of the the
the the way that one would do it is
using something that's like a microarray
or something like this like a um
something which has a bunch of little
pieces of protein attached to different
sites and then you look at how much
binding there is of the molecule that
comes in uh to those
um uh to those different cells in fact
another thing about it I've seen two
demos recently of things related to this
well it looks like that's that's
beginning to work so to speak and that's
it's very relevant I mean the ultimately
the kind of can you smell it type thing
is is uh well the point where one's
still using dogs to sniff out explosives
and things like that it's it feels like
technology has not reached you know
there's a there's a bit of a gap with
technology there the dog's nose should
be able to be something that can be made
into a pure piece of sort of digital
technology but that hasn't quite
happened yet
let's see
um
um let's see gosh so many questions here
gloucester's asking how much of biology
is untapped they say they're in the
biology biotech genetics metabolics
field and it feels like most researchers
never leave the lab
you know
the amount of sort of information about
how biology works that's been
accumulated in the last few decades is
unbelievably large
the amount of kind of big picture Theory
making that's happened is
in comparison unbelievably small
you know in biology there are a few sort
of big meta theories the theory of
natural selection the Digital Data
characteristics of DNA
I suspect there are a few other kind of
big theories
for example in other sort of semi-big
theory would be something like the
operation of the immune system which we
more or less know although I think maybe
we don't have it quite right yet
um but I think one of the things that I
suspect is that there are some other
aspects of sort of big theories of
biology that still need to be
established I think the most important
are probably around Dynamic aspects of
biology that is there's an awful lot
that's known about the structure of this
or that kind of cell the um uh the the
structure of this protein and so on
there's a lot less known about the
dynamic processes of the interaction
between these things
so for example and people tend to say
whenever there's a thing that one has to
find in biology there must be a static
object that's somewhere out there in in
the biological system you can pick up
and say this is or that
well let's take the immune system as an
example
I mean there's the question of how does
one remember an antigen that one was
exposed to how does one remember how to
mount an immune response to that and
sort of a prevailing theory has been
well you sort of parade all these
antibodies 100 billion different
possibilities in front of each Androgen
and the ones that are a hit those are
the ones that can Amplified that's
clearly correct then how do you remember
which ones you were going to amplify
well maybe there's a memory B cell or
something that is the type of cell that
would produce the antibodies that you
need and maybe for your whole life you
have certain ones of these you know
memory B cells that are sitting
somewhere waiting to spring into action
it's like there's a physical cell you
could pick it up it's a way of of
explaining what's going on my guess and
this is uh kind of following on this
so-called Network theory of the immune
system from the 1970s is that it's a
much more Dynamic kind of thing where
you know you produce antibodies maybe
you produce anti-antibodies you produce
anti-antiantibodies you are in this kind
of dynamic equilibrium of producing uh
sort of an immune response that produces
an anti-immune response that produces an
immune response etc etc et cetera you're
in this dynamic equilibrium where no
individual cell is living for 100 years
but instead they're all these different
cells that are being produced and then
those ones are dying and other ones are
getting produced and so on it's kind of
you're remembering remembering rather
than that you are sort of having
something which goes all the way back to
the beginning as a single physical
object you can pick up so my guess is
that the the kind of Dynamics in biology
of sort of this graph of causal
relationships between things this kind
of dynamic structure of what's going on
that this will turn out to be a pretty
important part of the story of biology
but it's one that's as of now completely
untapped we don't have a way to measure
kind of the causal graph of the
interactions between biological
molecules we have thanks to things like
PCR and so on we have extremely
sensitive ways to measure the particular
particular static sequences that exist
on RNA and things like this but when it
comes to sort of the Dynamics of
individual molecules bouncing around we
now have good ways to measure that maybe
there'll be a way I tried to think about
this maybe somebody will invent it I
encourage people to do that
um that's kind of the analog of PCR that
amplifies up a dynamic process a dynamic
Through Time process so one can imagine
there are ways one can imagine that with
sort of Auto catalytic sets of molecules
and you say I've got this it's kind of
almost like a a um when you have a radio
antenna and you are that radio antenna
is is really good at having electrons
circulation in a particular way and when
the electromagnetic wave comes through
and it sort of can excite the electrons
in that particular pattern then you
detect the signal and one could imagine
the same type of thing with molecules
where there's a particular sort of self
uh self-closing loop of reactions where
somehow how when when there is a dynamic
process going on it somehow excites that
Loop of reactions which one can then
detect I don't know that's a that's a
speculation about how that might work
but my point is that there are these
kind of dynamic processes that we don't
really have a great way of thinking
about in fact our physics project has
given some ways of thinking about bulk
parallel puzzle processes and I think
some of those things are probably
applicable to molecular biology but when
it comes to kind of what can we do with
Biology you know I think one of the
things is biology is this is the sole
example as we mentioning earlier of kind
of molecular scale Computing and it's
one of the drivers for making kind of
nanotechnology and things like that is
if we have molecular scale devices they
are easy to interface to the molecular
scale stuff that is our biological uh
character you know I think there are
there are so many things that will
happen I mean I I think that you know
algorithmic drugs is one one obvious
thing where you think about a molecule
that is a drug where normally a drug is
just like the static molecule that binds
to a particular place or you know just
sticks on in some particular way but
imagine that you could have a molecule
that would essentially sense its
environment make changes to itself
compute something and then say yeah
that's a really bad cell I should go zap
it a little bit like the the sort of
cascader molecules the immune system
does but the um
uh but imagine that you could make a
sort of you know this is this question
about you know everything is made of
computers imagine that you could
actually make this drug molecule that
has you know all these little pieces and
it's it's Computing something it's
sensing things it's Computing what it
should do that's an example of something
one can uh think could could happen in
the future you know I do think that in
terms of
kind of the the future of biomedicine
one of the very obvious things there is
it's all about sensing more stuff in a
sense the uh a lot of things where you
know biomedicine sort of a goal for most
of us is you know stay healthy and and
keep going the way we've been going
before because if we're you know if if
we if we continue to go as we've been
going it's all good and then the
question is is anything going wrong and
you know we know in the case of for
example commercial airplanes
um that's some airplanes in general one
of the big changes over the decades has
been just tons more sensors and so yeah
you know in the past it's like well yes
there was a crack forming in this place
so there was a a thing that was going
wrong here or there and you don't know
until the thing kind of blows up in your
face but in in modern times there's just
lots and lots of sensors and lots and
lots of ability to even even when there
aren't so many sensors to be able to
take kind of broad spectrum data from
the sensors that are there and use
things like machine learning use signal
processing to try and sort of fish out
of that kind of Fairly noisy data that's
coming in things that are signals for
for example something going wrong and my
guess is that that in in biomedicine one
of the things that will happen is sort
of this increasing oh you know you get a
drop of blood I've just done another set
of these things because I always I'm a
I'm a sucker for any kind of um
new technology of this kind of of you
know Plum the drop of blood it's like
measure uh I don't know the latest
finder measured like 500 things I think
um knowing what that means is a separate
challenge
um and that mostly is but one thing I
think an individual biomedicine is if
you get the time series you're probably
coming out ahead because of the time
series it's like it's all flat nothing
changed it's probably good now my guess
is that things are more Dynamics than
one expects so when we get into this
level of detail things will always be
changing that seems to be true for the
microbiome it's probably true for these
detailed metabolite kinds of metabolic
kinds of things that you can metabolome
kinds of things that you can measure as
well and so there needs to be a much
more kind of learning about these kind
of dynamic processes in biology to make
progress on that
but I think the uh
there's you know in terms of the sensors
and measuring things there's clearly a
lot of opportunity there there's clearly
a lot of opportunity once we have better
sort of Nano scale uh devices that we
can make those become sort of the
Interventional story so to speak I mean
you know there's always the question and
it's complicated ethical questions
around okay you have uh uh the um uh you
know you have the capability to do this
it's very personalized to a particular
individual it's it's Computing what it
should be for that individual how do you
do the standard double-blind clinical
trial test on something like that really
difficult and you know what do you do
how do you kind of um
how do you deal with the fact that
you're doing something and you you don't
really have that there's so much
diversity in what you can do that you
can't really do a broad test I I suspect
that this very fact that you can measure
more stuff will help that story whether
that will be understood it's sort of a
regulatory level quickly I don't know
but it does tend to think one does tend
to think you know if you you try you
know a little bit of this weird drug
that's supposed to do some amazing thing
for whatever or this weird algorithmic
drug that has a whole complicated
algorithm for doing this or that or the
other thing and you're measuring you
know 10 000 kinds of things about your
your biological operation and you take
that you know normally it would be like
well I don't really know if something
went wrong you know I took a little bit
of this algorithmic drug and I don't
know whether that's going to cause me in
five years to start growing purple hair
or something like this
um it uh
uh but if you start to be able to
measure 10 000 kinds of things pretty
accurately and you can see oh when I
wasn't taking this drug the level of
these hundred things was exactly this
when I started taking it oh I saw a
bunch of changes then it starts with
this question well what do those changes
mean are those changes detrimental
et cetera et cetera et cetera and and
that would be a complicated story
because I think that this whole
phenomenon I call computational
irreducibility this whole phenomenon of
even though you might have a pretty good
model for how bodies work it's really
hard to kind of run that and uh and and
figure out what's going to happen so
that these things where you see all
these levels are changing and you know
maybe in 20 years when if you keep doing
whatever you're doing in 20 years those
levels are going to cause some horrible
disaster for some organ or something
um but it's very hard to predict that
but again perhaps what will be
increasingly the case is that it's more
a kind of real-time thing of you know
you you try and well it will require
some Theory I think
um of figuring out you know oh this
thing went off track is that a problem
is that not a problem you know maybe
that's actually good that it went off
track maybe that makes you a superhuman
so to speak to have that be in this form
anyway let's see uh
yeah I mean I you know my basic answer
to uh you know what will happen with
Biology what one of the things to say is
that you know Fields go through these
kind of sort of periods of great growth
when some new methodology is invented
then they kind of level off and they go
into the cruise cruise mode for 50 or
100 years or something you know I think
biology has been very energetic in the
last few decades as sort of the methods
of molecular biology really came online
um I think the theory part has been
really lagging behind in my view and
that's partly a consequence of the very
size of a biological Enterprise and the
fact that it's kind of value system is
very much against Theory and purely well
what can you measure you know what what
are the what are the kind of
experimental results uh what are the
kind of unbiased experimental results so
to speak rather than ones informed by
some Theory but I think you know things
like Gene editing crispr these kinds of
things that's a yet another kind of
major kind of delivery of a thing or a
pluripotent stem cells they're just a
whole bunch of these kinds of of
remarkable sort of uh broadenings of
what's possible or now you know RNA
vaccines things that things like this
that are you know things that kind of
expand the toolkit of things that one
can be making use of in biology and it's
now sort of the the development of
what's possible with these things uh you
know it's it's unclear how quickly it
will go in most fields that I see that
involve um it's kind of like a five to
ten year story when there's a new
methodology it gets worked out in that
period of time in biomedicine there's a
complicated driver which is the whole
regulatory approval process and testing
and so on which extends those times I
think and so there are things where
people you know for example
immunotherapy for cancer people have
sort of believed that's going to work
for 50 years but it's still in fairly
early phases in many ways you know I'm
sure that there'll be a lot more that's
discovered about that and eventually
people will say oh we finally got it you
know we finally know how to do this but
it took a really long time and part of
that really long time had to do with oh
you have to do these tests maybe the
effect is quite subtle you have to
really I mean one of the things that's
difficult that's the interesting thing
it's a little bit like natural selection
so you know if biology and evolution is
trying to innovate it can have a really
hard time if there was a case where
somebody discovered Wheels I say
somebody discovered Wheels I mean some
organism some type of uh I don't know
some type of reptile discovered Wheels
um and was able to just like wheel
itself around with the greatest of ease
so to speak the problem is it probably
dies before it makes it to four wheels
that is when it has a sort of partial
wheel that more or less turns but it's
getting this nerve bundle tangled up
because it's turning around
those reptiles will die out it never
makes it to the sort of high Innovation
it's an axle and a wheel because the
intermediate stages don't allow it to it
it can't make it past those intermediate
stages because it's always got to be
alive and reproducing even as it's going
through those intermediate stages and I
think some of the same kinds of things
may happen in medicine and medical
testing which is maybe there is some
incredibly clever way to do I don't know
cancer immunotherapy or something like
that but to get there involves sort of
this radical change which might be
informed by a theory if one had one that
involves a radical change and where to
get there in incremental steps where
you're doing oh yeah we're going to do a
clinical trial of this well no that's
going to fail just like the reptile with
the partially established wheel and axle
is going to fail it's only by going far
out where you're going into a territory
where you kind of don't know at all
what's going on and where where if you
get it even slightly wrong it's just
going to fail horribly that that's a bit
of a difficult thing to reach by this
sort of incremental approach so you know
that's one thing that may may come up I
I don't know whether that's some uh
that's a feature
um
let's see
uh
okay spare parts is commenting do you
think deep neural Nets can help us build
models of the human perceptual systems
with vision and audio how do we solve
the problem of getting accurate training
data for subjective experiences
you know I think that there's sort of
increasing evidence even in the past few
weeks of kind of a correlation between
sort of the fmri parts of the brain you
know pieces of the parts of the brain
that are kind of using more power when
you um using more oxygen when you're um
uh um
when you think about a particular thing
or look at a particular thing there is a
certain physicality that seems to exist
of oh for you for this particular person
they've encoded their information about
uh chocolate or something or the or the
taste of chocolate in this part of their
brain and so when they think about that
that part of their brain lights up I've
always been a bit suspicious about those
kinds of claims that you can really
localize in that way uh actually I
really want to know for llms to what
extent one can localize the thinking of
an llm when the when the llm thinks of
chocolate which weights are really
lighting up that's an experiment I I
still have to really do
um but uh
you know it could be the case it's
actually a good piece of artificial
Neuroscience so to speak to look at an
llm and say actually it's a good good
idea to just take an llam and look only
at the central part of the llm only at
layers you know like in Chachi PT it's
maybe 400 layers in the in the
artificial neural Nets maybe look at
layers 200 through 300 and just say
looking only at those layers could I
tell that the thing is thinking about
chocolate and is about to write some
some giant thing about uh how wonderful
chocolate is so to speak
um could I tell that from looking at the
sort of the innards of the neural Nets
and uh how does that and if if the
answer is yes well maybe it suggests
that we have a fighting chance to be
able to do that for brains
um and be able to sort of pick up what
we're thinking about that way
I think uh this question of well what
really is the subjective experience of
this or that thing perhaps
I mean I I don't know to what extent the
kind of just watching what part of your
brain lights up is going to give you
information about what one thinks of as
the internal subjective experience I
mean I think
in
at some level
it I think in the end
it will be
we'll sort of know what subjective
experience is
kind of this complicated pattern of of
um of bits so to speak that some part of
our brain experiences and somebody else
will have a different one you know an
interesting experiment you can do with
gpt4 is to ask it to take something some
piece of text and compress it in a way
that it is going to understand and it'll
produce some very compressed
representation uh you know you in terms
of some random characters you can tell
it to use emoji if you want and then you
say uncompress it and it will produce
something that is uh not
uh not word for word typically the same
as what went in but has the same kind of
ideas
and it's similar to the way that um
autoencoders work where you're kind of
saying let's take this let's let's
extract the degrees of freedom that are
really important in this information
compress it down and then you can expand
it back up again because you're
capturing the parts that are really
important it's sort of notable it seems
like gpt4 can do this but GPD 3.5 can't
it's like it got some kind of
self-awareness of being able to encode
something for itself that it didn't have
with that with a smaller number of uh of
connections and so on but but exactly
how that works I don't know
um I think
um
let's see there's a question here
about uh
uh from internet professional about
technology and science means nothing
until we can chat with our cats and dogs
will this ever be possible
you know I've been wondering and chasing
that particular question for a long time
um it's uh
uh I think
in modern times of llms and so on this
is the moment when we should be able to
solve that problem
and when we should be able to uh kind of
well a thing that I was interested in MO
15 years ago 10 years ago I forget
um sort of even got started on a project
of making an iPad it was right after the
iPad came out so 2010-ish
um that uh making my goal was make a
game that a cat can win against its
owner
and or alternatively make a Minecraft
for cats and dogs or cockatoos or
whatever else
something where the you know some
non-human animal can create a thing I
mean we humans have built for ourselves
all these means of creation from
keyboards to paint brushes to whatever
else which aren't particularly an easy
form factor
to use for a uh for an organism that
doesn't you know that has pores rather
than hands or whatever else so the
question would be
um and maybe has simpler vocalizations
than we have and so the question would
be what if you could construct such a
thing if you could figure out you know
if you give the cat a means of creation
so to speak to make its painting or
whatever else what painting will it make
and uh uh and and you know we might just
say well the cat made this random
painting I don't know what it is it's
just a random painting it didn't mean
anything
well you know you can go back and look
at cave paintings that our species made
you know 20 000 years ago and they're
just sort of splotches of this and that
and hand prints in different places what
do these mean we don't really know we
don't know if they're kind of random or
whether they have some definite
communication that is now lost to us
today and so similarly I think the the
non-trivial question is can we correlate
whatever the cat makes or something with
things that we understand now it's worth
remembering that uh let's say dogs with
their you know very sophisticated
olfactory sensors they're a lot of their
world is surely encoded in what it
smells like so to speak not for example
what it looks like
so for us even if we could sort of talk
to the dog the dog will be describing
its experiences in large measure
probably in terms of olfactory space
rather than sort of physical space
and and so then the question is well how
do we have that conversation with the
dog given that it's talking about things
that we really don't have an
understanding of because that's not been
our sensory experience of the world now
even things about which we don't have a
sensory experience of the world we get
to learn about them you know we built
telescopes we've got microscopes those
give us a way to extend our sensory
domain and eventually we get intuition
about what things look like under
microscopes and so on we can talk about
them and presumably the same thing will
happen with with uh with smell and so on
I mean even at an even simpler level we
we already have perfectly good infrared
sensing devices that let us sense sort
of uh you know heat and other things
outside of the um the standard visible
light spectrum and
um
but it's not clear how to feed that
information to us you know you can have
a sort of uh you know a a thing that
shows you the infrared image of things
and you can make brighter the things
that are hotter and so on but there's
sort of color in the infrared there's
just like there's red green blue as sort
of bands of of um uh visible light so
they're perfectly well bands of an
infrared light but how we communicate
that to our brains is not clear I mean
nobody has yet made the kind of obvious
extended reality interface for for
infrared for example and uh that's but
you know when it comes to the olfactory
extended reality that's even more
challenging and so then the the question
becomes okay if you're going to have a
conversation with the cats and dogs and
so on what are you going to talk about
one of the things that I think is the
case is that
there is at least and something Darwin
pointed out there is a emotional
connection the emotional the expression
even of emotions in animals and man as
he put it in one of his last books
there's a lot of similarity between
those you know the same smile growl
snarl you know all these different
facial expressions have a certain
commonality presumably these emotional
uh features are a consequence of quite
straightforward neurotransmitter levels
in our brains and those are in common
between us and lots of kinds of animals
so if it's like I'm happy today I'm sad
today those are things we're probably
likely as owners can communicate with
their pets perfectly well and you can
see from the tail wagging you know in
terms of sensory data I remember the
company I'm afraid I I have a suspicion
it didn't make it but it was a it was an
interesting company to run into that was
a tail wagging sensor company where
they're putting accelerometers on the on
the tales of dogs and
um and cats I think maybe but
particularly dogs and it was a question
of could you have communication with
your dog by virtue of the details of the
kind of the tail wagging of the dog
and um but in any case you know one of
the challenges here is well you know you
can talk to your dog what are you going
to talk about
and what is the dog's sort of view of
what happens in the world a lot of our
view of what happens in the world is
deeply informed by this whole stack of
culture and history and so on that we
have and our certain biological features
and those are different but well for
dogs we don't believe there is you know
for us humans there's you know a solid
10 000 years probably of accumulated
past down cultural knowledge where we
actually have ways in which there are
you know from one generation to the next
knowledge is is transmitted you know
these days perhaps with live streams and
things but uh um and you know human
language has been the the principle
mechanism for that kind of transmission
and that's something where we've
accumulated this big stack of of
cultural knowledge and so on and I we
don't think dogs at least have done that
maybe whales have done that we don't
really know
um and you know maybe the whales of 200
years ago knew less and had figured out
they hadn't figured out the great new
whale philosophy and so on or the great
new whale epic poetry that that's now
known and I think uh but you know this
this challenge of okay so you can solve
the sort of structural problem of
communicating with these organisms what
is the kind of what are you going to
talk about is an important question and
and one might think that uh sort of we
all live on the same world but we don't
really because there's quite different
sensory experiences of organisms with
different kind of sensor data coming to
them
let's see
so many questions here
uh
from insert something do you think it
will be possible to transition a real
living person into VR or code or will it
just be a JPEG of the person
well it's an interesting question
you know if
we had I think we've got pretty good
evidence now I think in the last six
months
there's sort of a dramatic change in the
evidence we have about what what it
takes to make a brain or what it makes
take a make make a brain-like thing you
know in the past we could always have
said oh you know there might be some
complicated Quantum effect going on in
the brain and it's not just you know a
few 100 billion neurons connected in
certain ways there's more to it there's
more molecular scale stuff going on Etc
et cetera et cetera I think what we have
learned through chat gbt and so on
nobody expected it but it's kind of
we really can see that a thing like that
is capable of doing very human
brain-like things so that really is kind
of the essence of the brain is really
being captured not completely in every
detail but the essence you know it's
pretty clear you can nail it with kind
of artificial neurons and so on so yes
it will be possible to make a thing that
can you know do a live stream just like
me type thing
um and uh out of artificial neurons
undoubtedly
then the question is okay I've got that
box it's sitting on my desk it's yakking
along just like me and then I say well
you know I'm gonna die and that box is
gonna live on
do I what is the experience of that in
other words do I say well gosh you know
the box is you know my my thread of
experience is not the experience of the
Box the box is another thread of
experience it might develop its own
internal experience you know I think
this is a thing that I've sort of
understood in the last couple of years
about Consciousness and its relationship
to physics
is a very critical thing in our
existence and our view of the world is
this belief that we are persistent and
we have a single thread of experience
there is a now there's a future now
there's this sort of thread of things
happening and there's just one of it for
each of us we're not experiencing you
know 100 different threads of experience
where we go off and this happens here
and that happens there and then maybe
they emerge later and so on we're not
experiencing that our our view of the
world is that we have a single thread of
experience now when it comes to what
we've understood from our physics
project that's not actually what's going
on underneath underneath there's this
whole bundle of different threads of
history of the universe which are
branching and merging and so on and
that's kind of the story of quantum
mechanics but we are also part of that
branching merging process and we're sort
of spanning a big bunch of branches but
we have the idea that we experience just
single thread of history and that idea
that we experience that we try and
conflate everything we try and say oh
this thread over here that really is
different no it's actually the same
we're going to conflate those threads
together we're going to say just like
saying you know we'll we're we're
sensing the I don't know the speed of
some fluid or something like this we
could say well let's look at every
individual molecule where it goes but
we're saying no no we're going to
conflate everything together and just
say this is one uniform speed even
though individual molecules might be
going at different speeds but we're just
going to say there's this one uniform
speed and that's all we talk about it's
a single kind of thread of what's going
on
I think that's an important aspect of
kind of our experience of the universe
is this single thread of existence I
think without that for example when we
talk about I don't know quantum
computers or something like that they
have many threads of experience when
they are trying to give an answer you
have to knit all those threads together
to get into something which is
consistent with our sort of single
thread of experience view of the
universe
so I think that our it is a very deep
aspect of our uh sort of existence that
we have a single threaded experience we
don't get to say oh actually we're going
to split our threat of experience and
we're going to do this and we're going
to do that at least so far as I can tell
that that hasn't been kind of the uh uh
you know it seems to be a core feature
of kind of Consciousness as we
experience it that we have a single
thread of experience and and so when we
have the copy of ourselves it's not
going to be that that copy could itself
develop a threat of experience and it
could be sort of Happily having an
internal
internal subjective experience but it is
different from our subjective experience
and the question is could we ever as
humans say oh you know it's we're
getting way too old we just need to
transition into digital form let's just
make the jump how's that going to work
seeing the box which is just like us
isn't going to do it
what I think has to happen is something
gradual
you know in other words if it is the
case that you know you have your brain
it's got all these neurons and they're
all firing and some of these neurons
in kind of are connected to something
which is gradually kind of offloading
some of the things that would other
Bears be going to other neurons I mean
if you took your brain and you replaced
part of your brain with a purely digital
element entity but the connections on
the outside are all connecting to your
nerve cells just as they were connecting
before then that lump of digital stuff
in your brain is you wouldn't really be
able to distinguish that now at what
point as you know let's say you're
you're putting these these neural
implants in your brain and you know more
and more of your brain is not original
brain tissue but is these kind of neural
implants that are emulating what your
brain tests you used to do at what point
do you suddenly realize oh my gosh I'm
All Digital so to speak now I don't know
I think that what's important in terms
of that experience is probably a
gradualness to it that if it's like you
know if one day you're all digital
you're just the Box on the desk it's not
you anymore and you won't perceive it as
you if on the other hand you're
gradually getting sort of more and more
of your brain as being sort of taken
over by uh
buy something digital then I suppose
that you could have the point of view
that yes it's it's kind of you know I
don't think that there'll be a moment
when you say oh my gosh I just lost it
you know back in the time of Descartes
and so on you know it was kind of the
idea the seat of the Soul might be in
the pituitary gland in the center of the
brain
um but uh you know I don't think that
it's going to be the case that there's
this sort of one little spot the
critical collection of nerve cells that
is the essence of of the US I don't
think so I think the whole brain as it
is being conflated into the single
threat of experience that's the
experience of the single us and that's
something where one can imagine as a
gradual matter replacing it
um and I you know that will be uh yes
that that's presumably what will happen
along those lines that one will have
something where it really could be the
the replaced human where you know you've
got an artificial brain basically that
was gradually taking over from your your
actual brain
um that would be my guess about how that
will work and I think it's certainly a
um
it's an interesting thing to imagine and
to even see where one can get sort of a
a sense of how that might work I mean I
suppose uh
there's a question I don't know people
who have prosthetic limbs for example
may have some experience of what uh
what it's sort of like as you as you
take over uh you know you make a
technological thing that takes over from
some biological uh some previous
biological version and you know what
that's going to be like for the brain is
an interesting one
the
let's see I need to go in a second here
but um
uh
um
there's anything I can think I can
attack quickly
uh
okay Wampus commenting isn't it too
early to assume you can replace all
parts of the brain but digital
technology
maybe I think it I I think that is you
know the idea there's something amazing
that is beyond
what we seem to be able to capture I
think that's a dwindling story
maybe I'm wrong but I think you know if
you'd asked me would one be able to make
a kind of a neural net that writes
reasonable human-like text and so on I
would not have known when that would
happen I wouldn't have even been sure
that would happen
um but I think now we now we know the
answer to that
and I think one can ask the question
uh
you know if you say oh what about the
creativity of the brain
well you know it's actually pretty easy
to ramp up the creativity of a large
language model you just increase its
temperature parameter you make it more
likely to pick words that aren't as
probable in its estimation of the
probability of the next word and it'll
suddenly start doing all these crazy
creative things that's just kind of
interesting because as you increase the
temperature as it's called to make it
more likely to use less words that it
estimated as less probable it at some
critical temperature seems to lose it I
don't know if it's a specific
temperature but it seems like it is
there's a specific point of which the
thing just starts yacking and going
crazy it's just Bonkers if you ramp the
temperature up really high and it's
starting to sample all these low
probability words and it then has to
follow on from those low probability
words the thing sounds just totally nuts
and it's sort of interesting that you
are seeing all these effects that are
kind of brain like a effects that um uh
you know if you've got it's it's kind of
like creativity is good but too much of
it and it's nuts which is kind of a
thing one's used to it imagining for
brains and you know so you can see it
you move the slider and for a while it's
like writing more creative essays if you
move the slider down it's writing really
flat boring essays move the slider up
it's very Lively it's writing all kinds
of stuff and then you move it a bit too
far and it's kind of Bonkers
and they're all these effects it's
really a weird thing I mean they're all
these things like one I was just uh
thinking about today actually was some
when you uh do kind of fine-tuning
training when you do the sort of after
training after the main training
training of a neural that one of the
things that's difficult is if you feed
it if you say now I'm going to tell you
about this this very specific thing you
just all the training data is about this
this this this this a neural net will
have a habit of forgetting what it
already knew so you have to kind of
intersperse old training stuff with new
training stuff that's the best way
people have found to do this and that
way it kind of is like it's still
remembering that it's got that old stuff
in there and it's um uh and and yet
you're feeding in a certain amount of
new stuff and I sort of remembered back
in the days of the Cold War and so on
this kind of whole concept of
brainwashing humans and so on of you
know you feed humans just one thing for
very intensely in some way that that
it's possible to then get the humans to
sort of forget past stuff and I kind of
realized that the that what one does
with llams is what one can do sort of by
mistake with an LM is essentially
brainwash the llm with the more recent
information and have it forget the
previous stuff
I mean I think that um they're just so
many bizarre analogies between what one
season LMS and what one season in in
human experience I mean I I do think
there's sort of this whole idea of llm
psychology and the whole idea of sort of
mapping the different kinds of uh uh
experiences that humans have
um to the kinds of things that exist in
LMS and LMS are certainly not the end of
the story in terms of what one can do
with neural Nets and so on but I think
there's sort of interesting things to
learn both for llms and for human
psychology and so on and Neuroscience
from looking at that analogy
all right I think we should wrap up here
well thanks very much for joining me for
this uh first episode of future of
Science and Technology
um I suppose we can we can imagine a
future where the uh uh the hopefully
preserved versions of these live streams
people will be able to look at them and
say oh my gosh what a goofball he didn't
understand that this is the obvious
thing that's going to happen in 50 years
um and uh I could talk perhaps sometime
about that whole question of what uh how
to
how to not be fooled by what you know
now into what uh kind of uh is what you
can't imagine some amount of time in the
future and I suppose for myself I've had
oh about 50 years when I've been
thinking about these kinds of things
where where I have some idea of sort of
what happened back in the past what
happens now what did I kind of foresee
what did I not foresee it's kind of an
interesting collection of what is
foreseeable what is not foreseeable how
you miss things which in retrospect seem
like they're obvious
Etc et cetera et cetera there are many
things with little lambs actually which
I think in retrospect are now obvious
but nobody saw them coming
all right we should wrap up here thanks
for joining me and uh see you another
time bye for now